hey everyone
welcome to this react crash course video
react js
is a widely used front-end development
library so if you're just starting
or wish to brush up your basics then
you're in the right place
this video will cover all the basic
concepts of react.js
first we'll look at what react.js is
then we'll see how to install and set up
the react environment
then we'll move on to learn the
fundamental concepts of
components props and states
lastly we'll conclude the session by
creating a simple calculator app
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already
make sure to subscribe and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update
i'm sure you're excited to learn so
let's dive right in
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react is a javascript library
used to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both
web and mobile applications now one
thing that makes react
extremely powerful is the fact that it's
open source
any user can access its source code
modify it and enhance it in a typical
model view controller architecture
react defines the view part of the
application it is also responsible for
how the app
looks and feels fun fact react was built
by jordan walkey
an engineer at facebook now let's go
ahead and see how react works in real
time
consider a typical web application say
instagram the entire ui
of the page is divided into several
components we have the search component
a profile description component stories
component
and a post list component these
components make the code easier to debug
and always remain discrete
components also make development and
maintenance of web applications faster
as multiple developers can work
simultaneously on different components
of the same web application
now let's see why react is so popular
these days the act helps in creation of
dynamic web
applications it also provides
performance enhancements now there are
several performance enhancements like
virtual dom
and one-way data binding we'll learn
about these topics a little later in the
video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve
compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently
released an extension called react
native that is used for developing
mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging
now let's dive in to the features of
react first
let's understand jsx jsx is a syntax
extension
to javascript using jsx we can add
html to the javascript file all coding
in react
is done using jsx it also helps in
making the code easier to understand
and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript
and html now let's consider a small
example
cons simple here is a javascript
notation
h1 tags indicate html again the
semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice
to include it moving on the next feature
is virtual dom
dom which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines
how documents are accessed and
manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy
of the real dom traditionally whenever
something changes in the web application
all objects in the real dom are updated
this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed
react now compares the virtual dom with
the virtual dom snapshot that was taken
right before the update
by comparing the new virtual dom with
the pre-update version
react figures out exactly which virtual
dom objects have changed
now react only updates those objects on
the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature
performance react uses virtual dom as
discussed earlier
virtual dog impacts the speed of the web
applications
we also took an example of instagram and
learned how multiple components can
affect the development time
they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding
this means information flows in only one
direction
one way data binding is specifically
used when information is displayed
and not updated remember that the
components of react are functional in
nature
that is they receive information through
arguments and pass information
via their return values the next
important feature
is extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications
it provides server-side rendering which
means that the application is rendered
on the server rather
than in the browser react native which
is a react extension is used for
developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them
react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript
a react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices
thousands of applications like facebook
instagram
pinterest skype use react native the
next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses
flux implements a unidirectional flow
which makes it easier to understand what
actually is going on
now let's see how it works when we
trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them
to the stores a store is what holds the
data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can
receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views
actions define the internal api of your
application
they capture how anything might interact
with your application
the last feature of react is debugging
react applications are easy to debug
thanks to the large and active developer
community you can practically debug
react codes within your browser
now notice the small react extension
icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code
and also easily debug it moving on let's
learn about
the building blocks of react components
state
and props are the essential concepts
that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built
now what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application
react divides the user interface into
multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element
is viewed in the application react
components remain discrete
and are processed independently another
feature
is reusability components can be reused
multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time
consider the following code snippet a
component is implemented as a javascript
class
having some state and a render method
state is the data which we want the
component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user
the next concept is state state of a
component
is an object that holds some data this
data
influences the output of a component
every time the state of an object
changes
the component is re-rendered onto the
screen now let's see
what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components
properties help make components more
dynamic it is important to define
all the properties their types and their
default value
props are passed to components in a way
similar to that of html tag
attributes now consider the following
code snippets
this shows exactly how properties are
passed to components
also detailed illustrations on
components props and state
will be shown in the upcoming videos so
stay tuned for that
moving on let's go through some of the
things that you should know
before you can actually start working on
react you should be familiar with
programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
javascript
and a familiarity with html don't worry
if you feel like you're not good at them
once you start working on them you'll
get a good hang of it finally
let's go through the impact of react on
the it industry
and get insights into the salaries of
react developers
statistics show that react developers
earn way more than other web developers
according to pay scale the average
salary for a react developer
in the united states is a whopping 91
000 us dollars
the average salary for a react developer
in india is 7.25 lakhs per annum
over the recent years react has gained
immense popularity
and is being adopted by many companies
according to the data by google trends
react has had a better growth scale
compared to other frameworks
like angular and vue statistics show
that front-end developers
have wholeheartedly adopted this
lightweight framework foregoing other
available options
if you are skilled and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react devotionally
we have facebook instagram netflix
dropbox
whatsapp among others in this video
we'll be learning all about react
installation on windows
to set up the react development
environment we need two things installed
node and a text editor of your choice so
let's begin by installing nodejs
we can head to the official node.js
website
save download node.js
so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version
so i'm going to go ahead and click on
the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation
you can go ahead and download a text
editor of your choice
so i'd suggest vs code so let's head to
the vs code page say download vs code
click on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows
once you're done with the installation
of both node and your text editor you
can start creating
your first react application so for that
let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it first react
now open your command prompt now you can
type in the path
for the folder that you just created so
say
cd users
first yeah now go ahead and type in the
command
npm install hyphen g
create react app okay so this command
installs all the necessary react.js
modules
now to check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in
create react app
version so you can see the version here
now let's continue and develop
your react application type in the
command create
react app and you can give a name to
your application
so i say my app now this should take
a couple of minutes okay once you've
successfully created your
they say to begin by typing the
following commands
so let's do that save cd my
app and npm start this should typically
start
your application and here we go all
right
you can also open your application in
the text editor that you've downloaded
so let's go ahead and open vs code
vs code file open folder go to your
desktop or the
drive that you've saved your folder in
first react
my app and say select folder so as you
can see
all your modules have been imported you
can click on app.js
and start editing in this video we'll be
learning
all about the most basic infrastructure
of react.js called components
so we'll be touching on topics like what
are components
types of components nesting components
higher order in pure components and a
brief description about component life
cycle
alright to begin with what exactly are
components
components are the building blocks of a
react application
wherein each component represents a part
of the user interface
now to make it more understandable
consider the facebook home page
the entire ui can be broken down into
several elements
say we have the credentials component
the signup component
the image component and the logo
component notice that
each component adds something to how the
home page looks
all right reusability is one of the
salient features of react components
one component can be reused several
times across the application
and this improves the development speed
components can also be nested
one component can internally consist of
several other components
in its minimal form a component must
define a render method that specifies
how exactly the application looks and
feels
a component can also receive properties
from its parent components
also you'll get a better understanding
of all of these when we start working
hands-on so don't worry
so moving on let's look at the different
types of components
first we have the stateless functional
components and then we have the stateful
class components
now functional components are typical
javascript functions that return html
now they can be contained in a dot js or
a dot jsx file
coming to class components these are
regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method
that in turn returns html they can also
be contained in dot jx or
dot jsx file okay then let's go ahead
and build our first react application
using components all right so i've
opened my text editor that is vs code to
build my application
also i suggest you watch the react
installation on windows video to help
you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start
building your first react application in
my case i've opened
a folder called react component tutorial
and here in my source folder
i have app.js now app.js
is the main component that gets rendered
to the dom let me show you that
here in index.js you pass app.js which
is a component that gets rendered
to the react dom so app.js consists of
several other components that can be
nested
so as you can see app.js is a functional
component
and before moving on let me get rid of
all the unnecessary code
so let me delete all of this
and return an h1 tag that says hello
welcome to sibling let me save it
and if you look at the browser you'll
have hello welcome to simply learn
now let's go ahead and display another
message say
h1 this video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser
it gives you an error so jsx uses a
conventional rule
which states that all html tags have to
be enclosed within a div tag so for
example
i say div and i enclose it so let me
save and check my browser again
here you go so multiple html tags have
to be enclosed within the div tag
moving on let's create a first
functional component
to do that i'll first create a folder in
my source folder
say components within that i'll create a
file
say functional component dot js
all right so the first thing we have to
do is import react so i say
import react from yeah
the general syntax for a functional
component involves
the keyword function and say
functional component now
you say return an h1 tag or i've already
used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you
how these components are exported and
imported let me show you the general
syntax for a class component
so i create another file say class
component
dot js i again import react
from react the general notation is using
the class keyword
followed by the name of the class
extending from the base class the
act.component
so going ahead i say class class
component extends react dot
component now the key feature of a class
component
is the usage of a render method so i say
render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is the class component
all right so moving on let's see how
these components can be nested
into the main component that is app.js
components can be nested into the main
component using
import and export keywords so as the
name suggests export feature is used to
export a particular file or a module
and import is used to import a
particular file or module into the
current existing
module so we have two different types of
exports you have default export and
just export or named export so a default
export is used to export
just one object be it a function a class
a variable
from the file and there can only be one
default export per file
and when you're importing it you can
specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our
editor and then functional component and
here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js
i say import name of the functional
component that is functional com from
and i pass the path this components
slash functional component also let me
get rid of these unnecessary
files here now let's define functional
component in our app.js component so
here
i say functional comp let's compile it
and check our browser here it says this
is a functional component
moving on to my class component it's the
same syntax here as well
i say export default name of my
component
and in my app.js i import it
import class comp from the path
and again i'll have to define it in my
return method i
save so let me compile it and check my
browser
it says this is the class component one
unique feature of
default export is that i can rename the
file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say
fc and while i'm defining it i'll have
to make sure i use the same naming
conventions so i say fc again
and when i check it it says this is the
functional component
there's literally no difference the next
type of export is the named export or
just export so a named export can be
used to export multiple
objects be it functions class etc from a
file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that
while you're importing it cannot be
renamed so let me show you how this
works
okay so let's create another class in
our class component
so i'll just copy paste this let me give
it another name say class com1
and the message that i want to display
is hey i'm another class
all right so when i'm exporting it i
don't want default
so let me take it off and say export
here all right
in my app.js while importing it i want
to import both the classes so i'll
include them within curly braces here i
say class com
comma class comp one and then again i
define it here
class comp one let's compile it and run
it
and here we go here you can see hey i'm
another class
so we've successfully exported both the
classes from the class component and
imported it back in
our app.js component one advantage of
using named
export is the fact that i can choose to
import the classes that i want to now
say for example i do not want to import
class component here
so let me take it off and here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
hey am another class the second class
got imported while the first class that
was defined earlier is not imported here
all right so next up we have higher
order and pure competence now i won't
get into the nativities of it because
they're advanced topics but to give you
a brief insight
higher order components are basically
functions that take in a component
and return a new component the whole
ideology behind higher order components
is to facilitate the reusability of
component logic
okay so let's see how this works let's
go back to our code editor
let's create a component in our
components folder
let's call the component click
dot js all right so here we define a
class
i use this snippet rce here we go we get
the entire format using the small
snippet rce
and here i'm going to make use of a
button now see i
use the tag button and i'll say
clicked one time every time the user
clicks on the button
the value gets incremented so for this
i'm going to use a variable say count
and i'm going to use the concept of
states so let's go ahead and define our
variable count
and initialize it to zero so for that
i'm going to use another snippet
called r const and here this dot state
equals my variable count initializing it
to
zero so let's define the count variable
in a render method
so i say const count equals
this dot state so every time we
click on the button the count value has
to get incremented
right so we make use of an event called
on
click equals this dot
update click now update click is going
to be another method that we have to
define now
so every time the button gets clicked
this method is called
so let's go ahead and define the
function so it is
update click equals it's going to be an
arrow function
and i say this dot set state
is nothing but count this dot
state dot count plus one okay and here
we say count times all right so once
this is done
let's import our component in app.js
so here again i say import
click from components click
and let's define it here so let's check
our browser
every time we click on the button the
value gets incremented
all right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js
wherein every time the user hovers the
mouse on the button
the count value increases so let's go
ahead and do that
i say counter dot js
i'm again going to use the snippet rce
to create
a class component and here in my div tag
i define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event
say button on mouse
enter i'm going to call the method
this dot increment count
okay so once you're done with that let's
go ahead and define the increment count
method
i'm going to copy the same code that
i've mentioned in my click.js
so i say copy this all right so one
change is that i
change the name of the method and call
it
increment count again let's define the
count in our render method
so i say const count equals
this dot state and here i change
x to com now let's go ahead and import
it in our app.js
so i say import counter
from components and counter
and let's define it here all right let's
save it
and let's run the code okay so as you
can see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button
it increments mind you i'm not clicking
i'm just hovering my mouse
okay to learn how higher order
components work we'll have to pass
counter.js and click.js as parameters to
give birth to an entire new component so
for that let's go ahead and create
another component for our hoc let's call
it
higher order dot js okay so i say
import react from react after that
i say const updated component
equals original component
that's going to be an arrow function
again and within curly braces
i define my class that is class say
new component extends react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return
new component and let's export this
say export default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js
and click.js and pass these components
as parameters
so let's do that let's go to our
counter.js and here
i say import updated
component from dot slash
higher order component and here while
exporting
i say updated comp and pass this
as my parameter let's do the same to
click.js
here i import data com from higher order
component
and here i pass this as a parameter now
here in a higher order component
we've defined a property name and
initialized it to the user
so we'll have to include this in our
other components that's counter and
click
so let's do that and here right before
incremented to
i say this dot props
dot name let me save it let me do the
same thing here
and save this dot props
dot name so if you go back to our
browser here you can see it says the
user clicked
zero times and the user incremented to
zero okay
so this basically shows how react
implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components
now another way to create class
component is by extending pure component
from react
a pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders
now how does it do it it does not
implement the should component
update method now you'll learn about
this method a little later in the video
now this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom
but a pure component on the other hand
ensures a shallow comparison
of states and props and checks if a
re-render is
actually necessary only then does it
render to the dom a react
component can be considered pure if it
renders the same output for the same
state and props
so let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code
and create two component classes one for
a regular component and the other for a
pure component now using this example
i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create
a purecomponent.js file i say
pure comp dot js so here i'm going to
use a snippet
rpce that is going to create a pure
component class
let me get rid of this export and here
in my
div tag i'll display the text say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create
a regular component let me call it
regularcomponent.js
and here i'm going to use the snippet
rce and the message that i want to
display
is i'm the regular component
so to draw a comparison between the
regular component and the pure component
let's create a parent component for the
two so let me create one here
i'll call it parent component.js and
this is again going to be a regular
class component
and here i display the message i am the
parent component
to change the state of the component
we're going to make use of a constructor
so let's use the snippet our const and
here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn
now we make use of the component did
mount lifecycle method
to set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn
about it a little later in the video so
moving ahead i'm going to make use of
the
method and say component did mount
and here i say set interval the first
argument
is going to be an arrow function and the
second will be the time interval
and i'm going to be setting it to three
seconds now within the arrow function
i'll make use of the set state function
to set the state
of my property however i do not change
the name i keep it simply on itself
moving on let's import pure component
and the regular component into our
parent component
and then pass name as a property so to
do that
first import pure comp from
pure component and then i say import
regular comp from regular com.js
and here let's say regular comp name
equals this dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this dot state dot me
now let's include the property name in
both our regular
and pure components so to do that let's
just say this
dot prop dot name and here
i again save this dot drop dot name
and finally let's import parent
component into our app.js component
so here i say import parent com
from okay and here let me define
parent.com so now if you look at the
browser
we have i'm the parent i'm regular
component simply learn and i'm the pure
component simply done we've got the
result as expected
now to check if the pure component is
actually re-rendering or not
let's include simple console.log
statements so here
i say clg snippet and here i say
pure component render
and in my regular component i do the
same thing i say
console.log regular component
render now let's do the same in our
parent component as well
here i say parent component
render all right so let's go back to our
browser
and inspect it in our console
first the parent component gets rendered
then the regular component and then the
pure component
after that for every three seconds only
the parent component
and the regular component is rendered
for the same state and prop
the pure component is not re-rendered so
in conclusion
pure components optimize react codes and
also improves performance
so coming to the last topic component
life cycle so basically comprehend life
cycle explains the stages the component
goes through
the entire life cycle of a component can
be divided into three parts
we have mounting updation and unmounting
so the first thing that gets invoked in
the life cycle
is component will mount it is invoked
right before the initial rendering
occurs
then we have the rendering method now
once a component is inserted into the
dom
component did mount gets invoked coming
to the next phase we have updation
when a complaint receives props
component will receive props
gets invoked set state is called when
the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component
state should trigger a re-render or not
to do that
should component update method is called
component will update is invoked
right before re-rendering after
re-entering component did update is
called that makes updates to the dom
and the last phase is unmounted
component will on mount method does all
the necessary cleanup and erases all the
allocated memory and cycles
moving ahead let's learn about another
striking feature of react.js
called props props short for properties
allow the user to pass
arguments or data to components a parent
component can pass
additional information to its children
using props
properties help make components more
dynamic
props are passed to components in the
way similar to that of html track
attributes now we'll look at this a
little later in the video props in a
component are read only
and cannot be changed one thing to
remember is that props are sent
by the parent to the children components
hence the children components cannot
make any changes to these props
now that we've learned about props in
brief let's go ahead and create our
application using props
if you're new to this tutorial i suggest
you go to the react
installation and react components video
on our channel
so back in my code editor that is vs
code i've opened a folder called
react props and now i'm going to create
a component
a class component and i'll call it class
props dot js so let's create the class
component
i give rce the snippet
and here i display a message saying an
h1 tag basically
[Music]
all right now let me get rid of export
here
and import it in my app.js main
component
here i say import
class props all right now we define the
class component in our render method
let's say
all right now if we go back to the
browser you see hello learners welcome
to simply learning
now let's say we want to individually
welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props
now let's see how to do that now we pass
the name as a property
from the main component that is app.js
to the child component
and render this onto the browser so
let's do that
so here while i'm defining my child
component
i say name
i save it and here in my child component
instead of learners i say i use the
keyword this
dot props dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have hello learner one
welcome to simply learn now let's go
ahead and welcome learner two and
learner three
so i again say class props name
equals learner 2.
all right so if we save and look at the
browser
we'll have all the three learners
displayed on the browser
we can also pass multiple props to the
child component
now say for example we want to welcome
the student from a particular place
so we say welcome learner1 from place x
so i can here define another property
say
place and say
place similarly i can do it
for the rest two say place y
now let's go back to our class props.js
component
and here say hello learner1
from this dot props
dot place let me save it and if you look
at the browser now
we have hello learner1 from place x
place y and place z
we can also display whatever we want
between the opening and closing tags
when invoking a component
now this is facilitated using
props.children reserved keyword now let
me explain to you
how it's done with an example here let's
split the self and closing tag
into an opening and a closing tag and in
between them
let me display a message within the
paragraph tag let me say
and in my child component after my h1
tag let me use a paragraph tag
and here let's use the reserved keyword
this dot props dot children
so let's save it and now if you look at
the browser
you can here see the message displayed
child component
so prop stop children can be used when
components do not know about their
children ahead of time
this is commonly seen in components like
sidebar and dialogue
that represent generic boxes so let's go
ahead and
create a button tag and check again so
here
i'll split it and add a button tag
and say click and let's check our
browser
here we go we get the output as expected
all right we saw the usage of props for
class components
similarly we can use it for functional
components so let's go ahead and create
a functional component
let me call it i say
import react from
react and then i say function
function props and here i return
an h3 tag
i'll say this is functional component
and i'll return another h3 tag saying
hello learner so let me save this
and let's export it export
default function
props and import it
in our app.js again import
function problem
function problem and here
in our render method let's define it
let me call function prop
name let me give learner 4
and place
place say a let me
close it and back in our functional
component
instead of learner i say
props dot name let me save it
now if you look at our browser it gives
us an error it says
props is not defined so let's go back to
our code editor
and pass props here to our functional
component
also let me define hello props dot name
from props dot place
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
[Music]
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go
we get the output as expected let's
begin and learn
what exactly is a state in react
typically a state is an
object that stores the values of
properties belonging to a component
now these values can change over a
period of time either via user
interactions
or network changes and the state helps
facilitate this functionality
every time the state changes react
re-renders the component to the browser
the state is initialized in the
constructor a state can also store
multiple
properties a method called set state is
used to update the value of the state
object now this function performs a
shallow merge on the new and the
previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learnt about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a component
they have significant differences so
let's go ahead and draw a comparison
between the two
firstly props in a component are used to
pass data and event handlers to its
children
while state on the other hand is used to
store the data that has to be rendered
on the web page
props are immutable once set by the
parent they cannot be changed
state holds volatile data and can be
changed over time props can be used in
functional and class components
while state is restricted to class
components props are set by the parent
component
while a state is generally updated by
event handlers
now that we've learned all about state
let's go ahead and build an application
to see the working of state all right so
in my code editor that is vs code i've
created my application say state
and here in my source folder i have my
app.js file
now here i'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary
code that i'm not going to be using also
i suggest you go through the react
installation on windows video to help
you get started with
creating your first application so let's
create our class component
say class app extends
react dot component inside i have a
render method
that returns an html tag let's display a
message
welcome let's follow the jsx conventions
and enclose all the html tags within the
div tag
so i say div class name equals
app we also have to import the app.css
file
import app dot css and
so we save it and if you look at the
browser we have welcome
now let's beautify our code to do that
let's add some styling
so here in my app.js class component
i say styles equals
and i say font style
and i set it to say bold and i say
color say teal and here in my h1 tag
i say style equals this
dot styles so let me save it and if you
look at the browser now we have welcome
in teal and it's bold
now let's go ahead and create a class
component to understand
state so first i create a folder and i
call
it components and inside this folder i
create
a class component and i call it new comp
dot js and i use the snippet rce
to create the class component to give
you an insight into what we're doing
today
we'll display a message asking the user
to subscribe to simply learn
once the user clicks on the subscribe
button we instruct them to click on the
bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we're
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier
we initialize the state object in a
constructor
so let's use the snippet r const to
create
a constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property
let's call it message and we display a
message saying
subscribe to simply learn let's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name
equals app and let's create an h3 tag
and within the tag i display the message
so i say
this dot state dot
message let's save it and now let's
import it in our app.js component so
i'll get rid of export here
and here i say import
new com from components and new comp
and let's define it here and say
new so we save it and look at the
browser it says
subscribe to simply learn all right
again to make our code look more
presentable let's add in styles
so i'll just copy the same styles that
i've added here
and i'll paste them here and instead of
bold i make
it italic and i change the color to say
purple and again in my h3 tag i define
style
and initialize it to this dot styles so
let me
save it and now if you look at the
browser it's in italic and it's in
purple
okay so moving ahead let's create a
button that
reads subscribe and once the user clicks
on it the button should read subscribed
and the message displayed above should
instruct the user to click on the bell
icon
to do that let's first create a button
the message that i want the button to
read is subscribe
however this message gets changed once
the user clicks on the button
so instead of explicitly mentioning
subscribe here
i create a prop i say sub
and i say subscribe here and back in my
render method
i say this dot state dot
sub so let's save it and if you look at
the browser now
you have a button which displays a
message subscribe now once the user
clicks on the button the message
displayed
should change to click on the bell icon
to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here
button on click i call
another method and let's call the method
button change okay so this method should
update the state and change the message
and sub values to do that we make use of
a set state method
now a state can be updated in response
to event handlers
server responses or prop changes now all
the updation can be done using the set
state method
this is the general syntax used by the
method we'll have a look at this
further in the demo now the set state
method conventionally
enqueues all the updates made to the
component state
and instructs react to re-render the
component and its children with the
updated state
now let's go back to our code editor and
look at the working of this method
now here i defined the arrow function
button change
if you are not familiar with arrow
functions i suggest you read up on them
and this is the general syntax and here
i say
this dot set state and inside
i change my message to hit the bell icon
to never miss an update and my sub value
changes to subscribed let's save this
and now if you look at the browser when
we click on the subscribe button
the message changes to hit the bell icon
to never miss an update
so moving ahead let's use a bell icon so
that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and a thank you message appears
on the screen
so for that i have two images i have
bell a
and bell b so i drag and drop both the
images
in my components folder all right
now let's import these images into our
new com.js file
here i say import bell a
from bell a dot png
and again i say import bell b
from bell b dot png
all right let me save it to display the
image on the screen
we make use of the image tag now this
tag has two attributes
one is the source attribute that
specifies the url and the other is the
alt attribute that specifies an
alternate text for the image
so here in my component i say i make use
of a paragraph tag
that will help display the image in the
next line
and then i use the image tag now since
my image changes once it's clicked
i have to define a property and pass the
event handler click
that will update the image so here
before
specifying the source let's go back to
our state
and define another property
that is image url and let's set it to
bell a since that is the image that i
want to display first
let me save it and here in my image tag
i say source
equals this dot state
dot image url and then we have the alt
tag and i do not want to display any
message so i leave it as it is
now let's save it and if you look at the
browser
we have a bell displayed however now
let's change the dimensions of the bell
i do not want such a huge bell
so back in my vs code i define style
with width say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this
and now if you look at the browser we
have a smaller icon
so once the user clicks on this image
the emit changes
and the message displayed here gets
updated to do that we'll have to define
an event
so let's go back to our vs code and here
in my image tag
let's say on click i define a method say
this
dot image change and now
we define this method here i see
image change i make use of an arrow
function again
and again i use the set state method i
update the image
so i say image url is now set to bell
b and the message is updated
to thank you happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser
we see the image and once clicked on it
the image gets updated and the message
changes
so finally let me refresh the browser
once and show the full execution
let me refresh following the
instructions let's click
on the subscribe button and now it says
hit the bell icon and once i do that
the image updates and the message
changes now that you know the basics of
react
let's look at a simple tutorial to build
a calculated app
so our demo is going to be about
creating a calculator using
react and node.js and so we have here
just a basic calculator nothing crazy
um but the whole thing is going to be
created with react
and so be using javascript to be
installing react
and installing the various components
such as node.js
and the different npm solutions that we
need so as you can see
my calculator works just fine and now
let's go ahead
and let's go and
install the different tools that we need
so the first one is going to be node.js
and we do google search on node.js we
always start with google searches
because it's the easiest way to find
things
and so we go to the default node.js site
and you can go to downloads and there
are windows
mac os and also linux installers
you can also download the original
source code and compile it yourself if
you want
and you'll also need a text editor i'm
going to be using visual studio code
it's just my favorite text editor it's
free works across all platforms
uh it comes with a ton of extensions so
you can get up and running really
quickly with it
um so we're just going to go ahead and
install the windows version i already
have installed so you have to download
it again
you also want to make sure that you have
the latest version of node.js
installed now with that node package
manager so we're just going to open up
our terminal window and validate which
version that we have
running and
we can do that fairly easily we can
just put in node version
and it'll tell us which version and
which means that's installed and same
thing with npm
node package manager we'll do npm
version and that will give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to
uh do that and we're gonna also now
create a
react app so we're gonna do install and
then it's gonna be create
dash react dash app that's the command
to create a new react app
and we're going to install it right off
our desktop
so let's go in and we'll put mpx
create dash react dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install
a folder on our desktop with all the
appropriate react
code and this will be just a
template application but it'll have
everything there that we need to get
started with
hit return and that will take a few
minutes just to install everything
and here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component and they'll be
the main component that has
all the information that will then be
saved on the screen then we have a
layout component
and that will be the actual look and
feel of the calculator
and the output component which will be
the results from the calculator
and then the output row and this will be
all the different tools that we will
need and here we have
uh our new folder right there
on our desktop um but we're actually
gonna go now into visual studio
and if you've seen any of the other uh
node.js videos that we've created you
know that i like to
work with the node.js in visual studio
code
because i can run terminal window right
there so i'm going to open up the folder
that we just created
that's called calculator i'm going to
open up the whole folder
not a file but the whole folder and
here's our folder on the left hand side
we have all the different files there's
our json package that has the
instructions for
what the calculator looks like
including which version of react and the
dom
and here's our default uh element
and as you can see because we're using
react it's going to
embed the code into a html page and so
we have a div
with the id of root that's going to
reference
some class files that we create and so
the app.js file has the application
code that we're going to be modifying in
a little bit and you'll see that it
actually then
references up to our
index.js file
and if in index.js file it has the
id element root which ties back to
the id element of root in our html file
so
we're constantly referencing and cross
referencing our application
and this is where we're going to be
doing most of our work
right so we're going to go ahead and
open up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
uh npm
and it's now going to have everything
running on
let's have localhost and everything
running on port 3001
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then bring up just the
standard default react boilerplate app
it's just taking a moment to load
i should probably get a faster computer
okay there we are just not patient
so here we have our basic boilerplate
react js
application nothing to create crazy
here so let's actually go in and start
working in some of our code so uh
see now yep everything's running where
we expect it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
and we can actually go ahead and if you
want to type
control plus c and actually stop the app
or you can um
uh in the terminal window you can
actually stop it
and you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message
there we go site can't be reached
and you'd expect this
we're going to go back in and
we're going to just restart our
application
everything should now be working just
fine
we're going to refresh the page and
we'll
see our default react app
[Music]
there we are
looking good looking good
okay so we're going to delete out what
we have there because we want to put in
our own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in and we're
going to be
modifying that class here in just a
moment i'm putting a default layout
i'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there i'm gonna
call this one
layout.js and this is where we're gonna
start breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
say import
layout and then
we want to do the path to our layout
components layout you need so we have
the dot because we have to go up one
folder that's the command for that
so dot up one folder components folder
layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows
to add the js extension
and constantly making sure that we're
saving
let's go over to layout.js
and this is our layout
let me do this using css
then we're going to import react
from react
and then select import
and then we're going to link to layout
css it's going to be a css file that
we're going to create
so we're going to have to type that into
layout.css
and notice we had to write out
explicitly that it's a css file
and so here we have
and then we're going to put in the
constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
you can
show up correctly
okay so we go to our web page now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to
change some of our pathing here just
quite quickly
so let's see now
we're going to move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
we run this
you know what i think we didn't we have
to update
yep i know we have to go back to layout
and
we have to start adding in some values
here
so that the application knows to lay
content out
so we just put in a
hello world there we are okay so that
shows us everything is pulling through
correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
i'm going to change this div
so that actually starts pulling in the
application
and put in the class name for calculator
and this will be a css reference
okay so you need to have some image
files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the
different elements that will need to be
presented on the screen
and then we'll have a css file that
we'll use to create these elements
and as you can imagine i've i've already
got this written so i'm cheating a
little bit because i know what i'm
putting here
but as bottom line is that
the calculator really is a bunch of form
elements such as buttons
on the screen but we use css to reformat
them so it looks more like a traditional
calculator
that's one of the the things that you
get comfortable
working with when you're doing web
applications is how to take
technologies that you're used to using
and then
modifying them so that they look
different and so in this instance
we're used to using button elements
within
an application so why not use
the the same button elements which
consistently work from
browser to browser and then just simply
update the look and feel of them with
some css so that
they they look good and here we are just
doing a very simple
on-click command um this is
some basic javascript that will render
inside of the
browser itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying
that the code you're writing is working
correctly
and we're going to do another button
and this is going to be the delete
button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
so let's start delete now and i'll click
event for that
okay we're just doing some formatting
here
okay so we just used
going through our code here make sure
everything looks good
and one of the things we can now do
because we've got a base line
that looks correct we can just copy that
and then we want the percentage sign
and then the forward bracket so this
so it gives us our two buttons so we
have a
start a new row here
i'm just gonna copy everything over just
make it a little bit easier ourselves
and then we're just going to find pin
the numbers
7 8 9
and then
plus symbol sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
and we just want to keep going through
making all the changes here so we
actually fill out all the different
elements
so as you can see most of this isn't
really
complex it's just the
uh you use the word fiddly yeah i guess
again the the fiddly parts of
putting this content together
so we refresh our screen we start seeing
all the different elements
okay looking good
we'll have to come back and make some
updates
to our css class names
and then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
[Music]
so
okay so let's now add some styles to the
content that we've created
we're doing our layout.css file
and so we already have some styles that
we created so we're just going to go
ahead
and for the for the sake of brevity
we're just going to
pull those over um
we can if you want to um and have us do
a more detailed video on how to create
the csc
css files and you know we'll certainly
do that but i think most you probably
know how to do this already
all right so here's our css file and so
we have our calculator keys our buttons
and the different types of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the
watercolor et cetera et cetera and so
i'm going to do that
here we have our
for our app
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the css then we just
have basic buttons
we have the css link back in we have
nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the results
screen and the
uh default logo so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
and we'll create a new folder called
assets and the assets will put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
and then we'll create another folder
we'll call this one images
and we'll put our images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn
logo
and then for layout we can then just
reference that in our image reference
so i'm going to import the logo
i'm going to import that from
our assets folder and under assets we go
to amg which is we have our image
and then we'll do the path for the logo
dot
so remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the source is from
our logo variable which is the as the
import of the image
put the width and we have to know it's
150 pixels and the
there we go 750 pixels wide
and the style that we'll reference from
css
will be
so just some inline styling here
generally normally do this i normally
have all my styling in my css
folder but in this instance because
we're just
putting up a solution i want you to be
able to see that you can actually do
this
in line so there we are however that
logo
okay so now we need to have the results
screen
make sure that looks correct okay
and so we're going to create a new
folder and this is going to be got our
output
js file and this is going to control the
output in that blue screen
and put our react objects
and we'll export that
and we're going to put a new file called
outputrow.js
so we'll put our instructions
uh this is going to be our component the
users will put their
results into
and now put row
and we're gonna put our instructions
here
so we're gonna like export default
output row
all right so we're going to start
putting together the code that allows us
to construct
our solution and we're going to update
the
output row.js file and
we're going to add in
our return value
so we'll put a div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field that
will be read only on the top
of our calculator and here we see our
text field here
and that will allow us to be able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
us to go out formatting
and we're going to put a file it's going
to be output row.css we're going to add
in our
specific css for
this output row
and as you can see we're just using all
of our standard html5
skill sets here
and let's go over to our
style it will pull in
our props dot text size
and then the default value
and so this is going to align with uh
go over to our css file and we'll update
that
output.js
make sure the results get returned
correctly
as we're tapping on the buttons
and so this will play in our output row
and the value will be
we bring our text size for our output
flow here
[Music]
and we're just going to put some sample
css styling here
nothing too crazy and we have two
rows
save that
and our two rows will appear in a moment
let's go into our layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output i'm going to
pull in those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some css styling to
this
so the top row will be the calculation
broken
out as we've written it and the bottom
row will be the results
and it's going to our css file here
we're going to copy over some css
and you have some
font styling we have our screen class
name
there's our screen here again this is
nothing no rocket science here and we've
done any css
um editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
and you see they're referring to a font
asset we actually have the font in there
we have to
pull that font over and
it's just a ttf font true type font
and you can use and any of the internet
fonts as well
google has a massive library of fonts
and there we are i'm going to change the
size of
our font so that the second row the text
is a little bit bigger
a little bit smaller and we don't have
anything wired up yet we'll do that in a
moment
that'll be the easy part of this
assignment
all right so let's go over and
now layout
okay so net input
set input
and use state
that way we can default the initial
state
and for the result the you state
the initial release date will be just
blank
there we go this is what you'd expect to
see
so the results are blank and this is
just when you run the app for the very
first time
okay so we're going through
and now we want to put in our actions so
we can have an event
when we click on any of the buttons
you want to take the value of the button
and so this you're going to be
any of these actions here
and we're just going to put together a
script to do the calculations
so as you can see so far we've put most
of this application
most of the hard work has been setting
up the base
react application putting together the
different files and folder structure
making sure we have the correct assets
such as
images fonts
css files laying out
our core structure in html form elements
and now um the part that we're doing at
the end here
is putting together the script that will
actually
write that actually do our calculator
uh events and and honestly and this is
going to be
um i've got this running here it's just
javascript
so there are lots of javascript
calculators
on the internet so you can actually take
any of those and
use those as a base for what we're doing
here
there we have an if there's an error
we'll do math error
result we don't expect to see that
and we'll just keep putting together our
code here
there are different results
so depending on
which commands you use so for instance
there is the equal sign and
we have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be seeing in
which screen
okay that's looking good
so we'll capture our value and
this is all concatenate together and
if there are any error messages
so if the value is c from the button so
if we select c
so we want to set the input to zero
to reset the screen
and if the value
equals and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to eliminate
the last character entered
and this is manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string
by one character at a time
again this is your standard javascript
control so we hit delete
and that gets rid of a character another
character
hit it again i'll get rid of the third
character
and
put if the string is
zero then put that as the value
all right
this allows us to test out our
application
all looking good so far
okay i want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values correctly
and here we have the
display and the input
it's all coming from here our output
class
and we'll put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always
want to go back and double check that
you have all your commands
all your variables lining up correctly
eliminate those
now make sure we have the answer and the
user entered there
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
you say that we'll go over and this is
now this is our local application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct
and we'll see that our calculator is
working so clear gets rid of
both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and this is the sample application
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against
and as you can see everything lines up
correctly and so you've seen how in just
45 minutes you can actually
write out your own uh
react js application with node.js
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so that
allows us to validate that we actually
created
we will restart the services
say yes i'm running on another porch
because we already have an app running
on
another port so it's going to run on
3001
refreshing the web page
and voila there we are there's our
application
up and running everything
looks really good working fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application
and make it a native application as well
right now just using it as a web
application
we're just updating some of the css
making it a little bit tighter
everything looking exactly the same
there you go that's your app all up and
running
and so with that we come to the end of
this session i hope you have a good
understanding of react now
thank you so much for being here keep
learning and stay tuned to simply learn
you